when the new stargate series finally
gets on our screens we actually get to
see the best elements from all three of
the first series will we get to see sgu
sga and sg1
teaming up and mashing together
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv
movie channel
if you are a regular site tracker you'll
know that i talk about stargate a lot
it's my favorite tv show but also
because i've got sources that work in
around mgm and marrying around amazon
i've been hearing a lot of rumors about
it coming back
but when it does come back what do we
want it to look like and what hints have
we had from brad wright
well bradley and joseph milose have said
and i've done previous videos about it
that he would love to see conclusions to
stargate universe and stargate atlantis
but he also wants to bring in new
characters as well so what could we get
to see could we get to see this mashup
of all of the best elements from those
three shows well
bringing stargate atlantis back into
this target series would be incredibly
easy atlantis is on earth it would be
the earth's most valuable resource and
you know they would be researching the
hell out of it there would be probably
thousands of engineers all over that
base
learning all of its secrets perhaps
while they're researching that they find
a way to
manufactures epms if they can manually
practice epms
all the world gets so much easier you
know starships with power cores and we
could build our own atlantis bases and
things like this but also maybe they
find some other secret which allows them
the possibility to actually rescue the
universe crew to actually go and save
eli
now that could then open a whole bucket
full of problems and that a new crew a
new sg-1 team needs to go and explore
needs to go and resolve
we've also got atlantis and potentially
the wraith
[Music]
the ori super gate has been inactive
since they sent their first wave but
it's been reported that the priors are
promising reinforcements for their
armies which are on their way and should
be here soon
now we can only assume that that means
more ships and these four are already
more than we can handle we have to act
now well why don't you try dialing out i
mean if it's powered by a black hole you
should be able to keep the thing up and
running almost indefinitely sure they
thought of that before they came all
this way rodney
could the wraith return to our galaxy
and become a threat once again to be
honest i don't think they'll go that way
i think they'll go with a new threat for
this series i don't think we'll revisit
the old threats a great deal
other than maybe in little special
episodes
and if we can do it again we can tie up
the ri super gate indefinitely even if
you were able to establish an initial
connection we need a new queen and a
dialing crystal capable where do you
have one and if you want to keep the
connection open for more than 38 minutes
yeah you need to find a yeah
this is not our first barbecue dr mckay
i am just saying the yield calculations
can be extremely tricky if not
borderline impossible
you may need me
colonel carter said as much oh
we weren't going to tell him that
from sg1 we know that amanda tapping
michael shanks even richard dean
anderson are very close friends with
brad wright and assuming brad right gets
to show run this with amazon assuming
amazon want him to do that
i could see him bringing back amanda
tapping as an executive producer or
director i think michael shanks would
love to direct a few episodes and
potentially appear and screen as well
and i could see amanda tapping to be
honest returning as general carter
because brad wright's already hinted as
much
but could we see some of the characters
from stargate atlantis return
joe flanagan is a massive fan of
stargate when it ended he apparently
tried to buy rights the show to make it
again he would 100
return to this new series
and again i would like to see him as an
older character now as a mentor for a
new team or he's even a leader for a new
team we're obviously not going to get to
see jason momoa return as his character
which is a huge thing sort of love to
sin ronan but
he's a big star now the only way they
would possibly get him is a maybe a
visiting for just one episode is if he
desperately wanted to do it and somebody
could talk him into it but i don't see
any evidence that he would really do
that two characters i would love to see
return from atlantis though and and
could work really really easily i'd love
to see jules state come back um as
jennifer keller i thought she was a
lovely character but to be honest i just
love the actress i fell in love with the
gym firefly and i would be more than
happy for her to return again um i'd
love her to be a staple of the show but
you know um i think there will be
focusing around new crew but one actor i
would love and killed to see return is
david hewlett mckay was my favorite
character from atlantis and i'd love to
see him return out of here i'll stay in
guard
hey
thanks for the rescue oh hey uh no
problem no you should be saying thanks
for the rescue
oh uh
right
thanks you should have you out of there
in no time this won't take long at all
oh my
what they changed the codes
but you can crack it right you need to
get us out of here yeah of course i
can't just give me like one or two
seconds
so i guess that frozen replicator plan
didn't pan out yeah not so much how's
that plan b working for you good
actually it's more like uh plan c
i would season c4 if you catch my drift
no
let's just say that we're concerned the
deadliest won't be able to carry out
your standing orders
what
to destroy atlantis with nuclear weapons
i thought we were past that why are we
going back to that yes it's the only way
can you do that yeah if we plant charges
in all 10 of the shield emitters before
the deadliest arrives that way when the
replicators try to activate the shield
the c4 detonates the deadlifts beams a
warhead into the city and we all get
vaporized
that sounds more like a plan f doesn't
it as in we are totally we can find our
way i've already done a video about
stargate universe and what actors could
return from there so please go and check
that out but from a story point of view
it just makes sense let's drag the
elements of all of the other great shows
in together and use that as a platform
to create a new show and to launch a new
show from
we've got colonel alliance that would be
my guess they haven't introduced
themselves they started shooting the
minute they came out of hyperspace
our shields are holding but we're not
the target
what's heading our way we'll squadron of
gliders and a troop transport cut them
down some but the rest will be on your
doorstep in less than three minutes
it means it just makes sense that the
first series would have elements of all
of these brilliant shows in and it does
actually line up with what i'm being
told about what amazon want to do with
the series because they are looking to
have series that interlock with each
other and influence each other and
having more than one series running at
once they really want to do a disney
style marvel esque project with stargate
i was also told that look at the game
timekeepers when it comes out because
that will really give you a hint of what
amazon are thinking they want to do with
the project moving forwards and the
timekeepers game does jump between
elements of the first three series it
does jump through time we do see the
goal world we do see the aura we do see
other bad guys from the different time
periods so that really does give us a
hint of what we might see with this new
series of stargate something that has
all of the elements of the original
three series in it we also know that
we're not getting a hard reboot this
will be a soft reboot a new story with
new characters so that means all of the
stuff that happened before still exists
and would be very very easy to draw into
the new show and to make fans very very
happy because let's be honest
we're going to be nervous about this new
project
they could get it very very wrong
one way of making fans very easily and
very quickly happy is to bring elements
back that they love from the original
series this is maybe a little lazy it is
maybe a little cynical of me to suggest
that this is how producers think but
let's be honest brad wright could hit a
home run with this very very easily and
a lot of these actors would love to come
back because they love the project
joe flanagan for example loves a project
david hewlett loves the project
amanda tapping michael shanks have shown
how much they love it by doing these
companion podcasts with brad wright and
reading these computer generated scripts
so so let's see what happens but guys
please get into the comments tell me
what you think do you think this idea of
a mashup of all the best bits from the
first three series would be a good idea
as a platformer as a foundation to then
launch a new show from i'm not saying it
should necessarily be
the bulk of the show i do want to see
new characters and i want really the
show to be based around those new
characters
but to have elements from the different
shows involved in the new series seems
like
a sensible and basically logical way of
creating a foundation for that show
what do you think they'll get in the
comments
excuse my terrible voice i have a head
cold so please if you are new to the
channel ignore that like and subscribe
anyway also you can consider becoming a
fully fledged side tracker hit the join
button it really supports the channel
also there is merchandise stargate
related t-shirts and glasses and
everything on sitetrek.com please go on
there have a look there's a link in the
description as always guys please stay
safe i'll see you next time
[Music]
you